well if you had um you had a bunch of
surveys that we collected over the last
couple weeks and I think we were going
to present to the gals as well too do
you have those are you talking about
like the poll results you were talking
about yeah there was a poll that was
flipped around the other way it was one
that was given to guys about
um IQ Notch count and income I think but
we had it flipped around the other way
what was the other one
well that's something we just I just
came up with where if we were gonna like
ask women of the three of these three
guys which one would they pick so there
was a poll that got put out on YouTube
yeah guys yeah
um
um yeah so there was a there was a poll
where it was I'll have to look exactly
there was a poll and this guy basically
goes
let's see
chat here rich
so it was for guys right which of these
three girls
um with guys most want to marry uh the
first one was she has a body count of 20
she has 105 IQ she makes 120 000 a year
woman number two has a body count of 50
has 130 IQ she makes 90k a year and the
woman number three has body count of
zero eight IQ of 80 and makes fifty
thousand dollars a year
um I'm curious uh to the panel if you
want me to read them off again I will
but here I gotta share my screen because
I actually shared it on my timeline here
so don't share the results just yet
because I'm curious to see what
okay they might because I think this
goes back to you know what do we think
men really want
um and so does anybody have a guess one
two so basically the three options again
are you know do women think that men
want a low body count with with sorry
zero body count IQ 80 50 50 000 a year
income body count 50 IQ 130 which is
high it's Beyond average ninety thousand
dollar a year income or body count 20
with an IQ of 105 with 120 000 a year
income so I guess the question is what's
what's what do the ladies think is most
important to guys Purity body count of
zero
body count zero does everybody all agree
with that because I didn't even get the
other stuff you just jumped on there
right away yeah sorry I would agree with
that too
yeah I think
yeah I think that's probably more
important than the amount of money that
they're making I think most yeah I think
most men uh I think most men who took
the poll would say
that the body count of zero
um IQ of 80. I'm not sure what that what
that looks like but I still think that
men would choose the third one okay so
it's unanimous that all the ladies think
that Purity is important to men so after
that it's income and it's smarts
um like how much of a priority I mean I
suppose you could have a high income and
be dumb but it's not likely they're
usually correlated
um but how important like
you could have a gal that's got a body
count of 20 but makes 120 000 a year
which would be a hundred thousand
dollars more than the Virgin for example
I mean
do women think that income or a woman's
income is important to guys when we're
assessing you know like women out
depends on the man
can you elaborate on that oh
um sure you know there's some men that
also want to take a back seat just like
some women do and they you know
want to be stay home Dad and so are you
attracted to men that want to take a
back seat oh no me personally no are any
of the women on the panel attracted to a
man that would want to take a back seat
and be a stay-at-home dad and take care
of the house while you go off to work
and Chase excellence and bring home the
bacon
not particularly nobody's excited about
that but I think so that what was the
option she has like a body count of 20
makes 120 000 and what was her IQ in
that one 105 which is average yeah I
feel like that's probably the the best
option because I do think that men want
a woman who has wisdom and can be like a
a companion of the mind as well
20 not ideal but I mean I I don't know
but somebody somebody pointed out in the
chat here that 80 is a literal art
um so that's I think 70 and below I
think it's like 80 is walking I think
the I think the 2120 105 or whatever of
those three but also I do want to say
that
um uh Anna's there are men who will not
date women who do not have master's
degrees and don't make enough money
because I've been turned down by men for
those reasons in the Bay Area generally
men who are in like Academia
um or that turned down because you have
a college degree is that what you just
said no no she doesn't because I don't
have a master's degree oh
um
and then income also because there are
men who want to do like a 50 50 income
split and so they do care about a
woman's income so I will there are men
who want that because I have been
rejected for not having a master's
degree and not making a certain amount
of money that does exist let me ask you
a question Nicole were those men strong
masculine virtuous like men like like
Alpha chat sort of thing or were they
more not that
no they weren't
they weren't them
are considered successful right and even
a couple are in the public eye
so
see that's a lie that I was sold too
right when I was younger is I believed
in
you know like the Twin Towers story you
know like the story of equality where
you know we go and conquer the world you
know together sort of thing like my
ex-wife is a lawyer right and I was an
entrepreneur at the time when I met her
uh you know we built a custom home
together blah blah and all that stuff so
it was like I was I was about you know
that and in hindsight there was benefit
to that because if you have to untie the
knot here in Canada there's no like
Equalization of payments or anything
like that if they make about the same
money as you so that was that was a
blessing that I didn't uh plan or
predict for I get it and I understand
why guys think that especially when
they're sort of like plugged into the
Matrix you know sort of stories but
that's that's not something that I would
recommend today like I wouldn't follow
that route today and I wouldn't
recommend to guys to follow that route
where it's like well you know if she
doesn't have degrees then you should
disqualify her like I think that it's
more important and all the ladies
alluded to this immediately I didn't
even get to the other ones you're like
body count zero like like even on a body
count zero right away that's the first
thing that guys want I think that guys
should put a priority on that especially
if you're going to want to have children
because we've seen the data on that I'm
not sure you know if you guys have seen
the data on promiscuity uh you know
they've studied are y'all familiar with
it you know
the chances of divorce if you invite a
promiscuous woman into your life uh for
marriage to make her the mother of your
kids is significantly higher
um the chance of you being together if
you marry a virgin is like 80 after 10
years and it drops down at like 30
percent if she's had eight or more
Partners so
go ahead sorry no no I just
I have done a lot of researching
research and I just feel like
there's so much more to marriage than
just the woman's body count and her
level of promiscuity like yeah there's
yeah there's loads to it but if you
correlate her her past for sexual pass
with the amount of men that she shared
her body with the chances of that
marriage lasting uh is much lower than
if she was a virgin on the day of the
wedding
if a woman is a virgin you know waiting
to get married if she's also seeking a
husband with those same values if that
has anything to do with the correlation
of the marriage working or not and not
whether or not she's had sex with 20
other men and she just hasn't I don't
know that's actually a very good
question and it's and it is important
but it's not as important with men so a
guy could be with like 100 women and
still want to be in a monogamous
marriage and have a whole bunch of
children with you and stay with you for
the rest of your life but the chances of
it being successful over over a
prolonged period of time dramatically
goes up the the fewer men that you've
been with
um it just seems that women have a
difficult time staying pair bonded to a
man if she's been with a bunch of men in
the past because the theory seems to be
that well if she's been with 50 guys and
if you're number 51 and things don't
work out then she's already exited that
50 times so it's not a big deal she'll
she'll find a way to you know wrap it up
and call it a day whereas if it's zero
or one or something like that
um it's it's tougher and it's less
interesting to you and you're more
committed to it and sometimes there's
cultural sifts sometimes there's
religious stuff that sort of plays into
that but the truth of the matter is is
when you study the data promiscuity is
not a desirable trait and a wife and I
think that most women inherently know
that in fact you inherently know that
Anna because before I even got to the
other data you're like zero right yeah
so I mean you can't sweep that under the
rug that's just a fact of life
um yeah but but I also think there's a
flaw in the poll you know and choosing a
girlfriend do you know how many people
she slept with probably not do you know
her IQ or what money she makes no you're
gonna go off of based on is she
attractive yes or no do I want to date
her have sex with her whatever and then
the more you find out and then that's
when you decide probably I'm just
throwing this out there if you want to
commit to that person or not yeah I
think it's just assuming that that you
know the information it's just it's just
basic information that you know that you
know so so it's in theory but also it's
about marriage it's not about what I
take this girl out on a date and sleep
with her this is like you know you
assume the thing those things are going
to come out in a proper courtship in a
vetting period where God takes anywhere
from you know 18 months to multiple
years before he does anything like that
so those those things leave Clues you
know the amount of money that she makes
and her level of smarts and you know
again you're yeah you're you're very
rarely going to ask a woman like oh how
many guys have you been with and have
them give you an open and honest answer
as much as they say which is so
interesting because it's such not if
it's such an a big deal these days and
why do women still lie about it and why
are they so secretive and wireless
Because deep down they understand that
men value Purity and they're trying to
kind of protect their innocence in a way
but you can you can you can you can see
that you know you can date it and you've
been around enough women you can
understand like which ones are a little
more you know promiscuous at least than
others I think for me depending on how I
would answer that question how long do I
know this man that's asking me how many
people I've been with if it's a first
date and you want to know how many
people I've slept with I'm I'm just
going to tell you I'm not going to
answer that question because at what
point would you be comfortable with
answering that question if we're dating
if you're officially my boyfriend
Facebook official I'll tell you anything
you want to know
and so Facebook Facebook official is
like the the test yeah are you in a
committed relationship on Facebook my
grandma if my grandma I'm not interested
like yeah okay
yeah interesting I think you may run
into I don't know again I can't predict
the future but
when a guy is going to contemplate
whether he's going to take you seriously
and become a Facebook official that's
something that's going to be you know
important
you know so I it's that that therein
lies sort of the power stroke because I
know there's I know plenty of guys out
there that
um
they're not going to give away their
commitment to and and commit to a woman
with a checkered past that is not if
their goal is to be you know exclusive
with you and have kids with you and get
married with you down the line they're
gonna go after women where
their best bet of having those kids and
having a successful long-term
relationships slash marriage is is going
to be you know the highest it could
possibly be so it's
I think that's going to be a difficult
conversation
um potentially if it's well I'll tell
you that when there's a ring on my
finger or I'll tell you that when you're
fully committed to me
and then it becomes almost like a gotcha
in some sort of fashion
see like the thing about about
that as an achievement I'm gonna call it
an achievement because I think that guy
is consider an achievement whereas women
tend to disagree with that but it's hard
for men to rack up notches it's not hard
for women it's very easy for women to do
it so I think if you have that
conversation when women hear the number
it it it's like okay so other women have
wanted this guy and other women have
been with this guy and you know as long
as you have a disease or something like
that but like he's he's proving his
Worth right he's proven that he's got
value and that he can accomplish
something that he can do things because
he's because he's done that even though
it may not sound uh pretty or sexy or
romantic or any of those things you're
not generally disgusted by it I don't
think unless it's like a ridiculous
number and the person's you know totally
disgusting but I think men on the other
hand though I mean like advice for
ladies out there I would not be giving
out numbers like that
wait can I interject really quick what's
what's a disgusting amount of number for
men and what's a disgusting amount of
number for women because I feel like
there's probably a difference there
that's that's all going to depend on on
who you ask so maybe we should ask the
ladies what would be a discussing number
that would turn you off a guy
I mean I would prefer someone
probably under I mean I guess it depends
on
how many people I've slept with
but like I feel like there's like a
ratio like I definitely wouldn't want to
be with somebody who slept with you want
to give us a ratio like five to one do
you want to give us a number like I
ideally I don't want to be with somebody
who slept with more than 10 people
um
I mean
that's probably like the maximum I
prefer it to be you know not near 10
even but what about a ratio like what if
there's a rate it also depends on how
old they are like I feel like
really when I think about
um
people like like the body count thing
about okay like when did you lose your
virginity and how long I guess how many
people and how many years rather than
just how many people people in general
but like how many from you know the
first time you're into it with a person
to now how many people has that been
um and kind of the circumstances around
that of
um I guess just the behavior around that
of like how proper misuse have you been
has it been in relationships or has it
been a lot of hookups is it for you Anna
like is there a ratio or is there a
number that would discuss you that that
would turn you off okay
um honestly that's not a conversation
that I have often with people that I
date especially now that I'm older sure
when I was like in you know high school
or whatever like oh how many people have
you slept with was all like always a
question to be asked but as I've gotten
older I don't get asked that question
anymore but
um I don't know I feel like for a guy my
age
okay
anything more than 30 I'd probably be
like all right what are you doing too
much but not that it's too much but it's
just like damn like
why
but not not that that would I don't know
I think anything more than 50 I'd be
like all right just stay away okay what
about you uh Nicole do you have a number
of discussed or a ratio yeah I I guess
I'm like in the minority because I mean
if a man's like and I know this is still
modest for some men but like 150 like to
me it doesn't so much matter like how
many are which women he's been with in
the past so like if a man's been with
100 100 plus women
to me it doesn't
change in my eyes his value but I will
say that the the problem that I'm
finding when I'm considering men who
have very high body counts or like we'll
say a hundred plus because I know
there's men who are you know four or
five hundred plus but the 100 it seems
like when you start getting around 100
plus women with a man
um they generally do not want actual
monogamy they want to be like monogamish
where third parties can enter into the
dynamic and so for me it's not a matter
of like how many he slept with because
of his value but I think once men have
had that much actual variety and have
had multiple sexual partners within
single experiences and over and over
paired with like watching pornography
and these things it's going to be very
difficult for that man to just be with
one woman sexually the rest of his life
and for me that's like not an area that
I'm comfortable I don't know you know
like I can't sign up for that and so
that's one thing that's like difficult
like yeah I don't care but I am finding
at that at those numbers you're
you're hard-pressed to find a man who's
like yes one woman forever they've had
too much they've had too many right so
you know so that's my only thing but not
his value okay
sorry Muffy you broke up there oh I was
just saying I wanted to come I want to
come back to that after we get to
Jessica yeah okay uh Jessica like you're
married obviously but I'm
yeah
um no you would comment on
um honestly it's not really like a big
concern for me I mean I think after like
30 40 it starts to get kind of too much
um I'm similar to Nicole where it's like
you know you get to a certain amount
where it's just like what's going on why
are you like why are you in the hundreds
or like even after like 50
um but to me it's not something that's
like a deal breaker like if it's you
know more than like 15 20 people I'm
just like yeah it is what it is
especially forever it's interesting so I
so I just dropped a poll in a live chat
and I'm asking guys because I think most
of the audience watching is men probably
at this point but um at what point here
I gotta open it because it closed up uh
how do I open this pool Men At what
point does your body count too much and
I've put five plus ten plus 25 plus 50
plus and right now it's polling where
five plus is too much for the vast
majority of people watching so it's
interesting that men and women have
different numbers where it turns into
disgust right like for a lot of guys
it's like you know discussed triggers at
a very low number whereas for women
especially like as you get older I think
women have the understanding that guys
will just you know like if you're if
you're dating a 45 year old guy and
you're maybe you know at Nicole stage
like you kind of expect him to have some
experience I think if you found a guy
that didn't have any experience Nicole
you'd probably question why like why are
you only with one or two girls or
perhaps even a virgin at this point like
that would probably be more of a turn
off than a guy with a 100 Notch count
right
um
[Music]
right yeah
whereas like 100 would be like that
would be normal because he's 45. well it
would be normal but like I said I just
don't know that that's a deal because
then I think
things to the
the natural variety right they've
um they've conditioned that natural part
of their brain that desires that it's
very hard to come out of that so but I
wouldn't be I mean if a guy was like oh
I've had you know what he said like
under five or whatever pulled for women
it wouldn't be a turn off for me but
most likely it's because he's
he's chosen that he's probably religious
like I you know I'm Catholic I make no
secret about it and
the men in the church often do have a
lower body count and so I kind of like
okay you know my whole phone is like a
larger one doesn't bother me but it's
just the variety thing
so when men stop that part of their you
know we don't discipline themselves
sexually like that
um
you know then that's that's what it is
very hard to to close that door
so I think you'll have to be most likely
those men need a woman who's maybe
doesn't need complete sexual monogamy at
that point I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full-length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out